nouveau numéro spécial consacré à la
fusion des régions bourgogne et franche
comté et pour répondre à toutes les
questions de nos différents invités les
deux présidents des régions le président
de bourgogne françois patriat et la
présidente de franche comté candidate
socialiste aux élections régionales
marie-guite dufay
on va commencer cette deuxième partie
avec du sport jean yves bourgeois est
avec nous dans le public
vous êtes membre du comité organisateur
de la coupe du monde de ski nordique de
chaux-neuve
et vous avez bien vous comme on l'a
entendu tout à l'heure avec jean michel
mazet des questions sur la future
politique on va tirer en matière de
manifestations sportives de la future
grande région effectivement bonjour oui
nous avons réussi grâce à un collectif
entre les bénévoles les partenaires
privés et les collectivités à rendre
cette épreuve de la coupe du monde
combiné nordique une des plus belles du
circuit mondial la région de
franche-comté a contribué fortement à
cette réussite par son aide financière
et logistique
elle est également partie prenante dans
le financement des installations
nous sommes au calendrier de la
fédération internationale de ski encore
jusqu'en 2018 à ce jour avec en plus une
obligation supplémentaire à partir de
l'année prochaine d'organiser une coupe
continentale qui est une coupe
continentale une coupe du monde b 1 sur
un autre week-end donc voilà est-ce que
cette nouvelle région va pouvoir
continuer à être à nos côtés pour
garantir la réussite et pérenniser cette
belle compétition qui est de ne nous on
souhaite bien sûr conservés est ce
qu'elles ont les compétences pour
écouter la nouvelle région n'a pas
vocation à arrêter ce qui marche bien et
a arrêté ce qui est excellent là où on a
peut-être des problèmes par rapport à la
nouvelle région c'est de voir si on a
des choses qui sont redondantes
alors là je ne pense pas qu'en bourgogne
est redondante part parce que faire
douze donc donc a priori vraiment tous
les éléments sont au vert pour que vous
continuiez que vous rajoutiez à la la
tranche à la tranche b et puis que un
chaux neuve soit toujours la capitale du
combiné nordique la capitale mondiale du
combiné nordique
qu'est ce que ça représente justement
pour paris pour la franche comté mais
demain pour la bourgogne franche comté
un événement comme chose mais un
événement comme celui là il va être sur
la grande région
je pense attractif pour les bourguignons
qui déjà viennent nombreux chez nous
pour faire du ski de fond la patrie
l'univers du ski de fond c'est le haut
jura c'est le haut doubs et c'est les
champs c'est les espaces infinis et
magnifique
les bourguignons ils viennent assez
nombreux ils vont y venir encore plus
nombreux quand ils vont découvrir
chaux-neuve jacques beaujean oui bah
écoutez c'est l'oeuf rassurant c'est
bien on va on commence à préparer la
nouvelle édition donc c'est très bien et
puis bon le les questions effectivement
par rapport à la culture tout à l'heure
sur les futures capacités
d'accompagnement c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je comprends que vous
puissiez pas à répondre sur des durées
au delà de l'année 2016 non mais là où
il ya la prise en compte du fait sportif
imaginez en franche comté en bourgogne
un week-end sans événements culturels ou
sans événement sportif qu'est ce que
serait ce territoire donc c'est pour ça
que la région et nous avons nos deux
régions
depuis douze ans avec raymond forni puis
avec marie-guite augmenter les crédits
pour cette erreur nous avons accru et il
ya des événements quotidiens
on ne peut pas laisser les petits clubs
qui vivent chaque jour de côté les
petits clubs qui font vivre les
territoires
on ne peut pas non plus ignorer les
évènements nationaux nous avons soutenu
le grand prix de monaco
nous ne soutenons plus aujourd'hui parce
qu'il parle aujourd'hui
mais quand il ya une étape du tour de
france dans nos territoires
chaque fois nous l'avons soutenu
qu'aucune finale de la coupe de france
nous venons de la soutenir par ailleurs
des événements nationaux internationaux
la région ne passera jamais à côté dans
tous les domaines du sport une voire
deux par contre par contre un avis oui
j'aurais une question concrète sur les
il ya eu des contrats d'objectifs
notamment en bourgogne en 2010 avec les
ligues les comités régionaux je crois
que c'est un peu le même système en
franche comté doubs et c'est pas tout à
fait pareil il ya des contrats de
développement de pratiques sportives je
prends un géant en franche-comté même
système aimerait pour justement ne pas
faire démagogie nous avons pas même
celle là est alors et bourguignons par
exemple aide les clubs sportifs nous en
franche comté nous nous nous aidons les
ligues
nous n'aidons pas les clubs donc c'est
un chantier mais la brink's entière et
les conventions qui sont aujourd'hui
passés soit avec des clubs sont avec les
ligues etc
elles sont valables jusqu'à quand les
clubs ils peuvent compter sur vous
jusqu'à quand est ce que c'est encore
une fois jusqu'au mois de mai ou est-ce
que voilà ça dépend encore des majorités
ou est ce que vraiment les contrats ont
été prévues sur plusieurs années non
tout sera redéfini avec les nouveaux
élus
mais là il ya un vrai chantier à voir
parce que nous n'avons pas eu la même
politique je pense que les deux ont été
probablement efficace en termes de
soutien mais elles ont été différentes
je pense que c'est bien aussi d'avoir
des politiques différentes donc c'est
important maintenant de voir comment
peut- être nous
appuyé sur l'exemple bourguignon pour
prendre des choses qu'on ne faisait pas
et vice versa mais tout ça dans un
contexte effectivement financiers
restreints elle sur les infrastructures
scolaires n'a parlé effectivement de
soutien financier au niveau des
événements par exemple comme chaux neuve
mais jean yves bourgeois parler des
infrastructures par exemple le tremplin
effectivement est-ce que là aussi la
grande région continue va continuer
demain mais il ya la tenancière danse la
grande région va maintenant c'est fait
aller je pense qu'on va pas nous
demander à chaux-neuve intrants places
supplémentaires
donc de ce côté là c'est bon mais
pourquoi avons été avons nous été aussi
déterminés et aussi volontariste sur le
tremplin de chaux-neuve
mais c'est parce que il était identique
terre de la force de la franche comté le
ski nordique
la neige le massif du jura c'est
vraiment une très forte identité et donc
je pense que chaque fois que cette
identité là où on sera présent et cette
identité elle va pas disparaître avec la
grande région
elle va être un des joyaux de la grande
région faut rappeler quand même que dans
le public dans les habitants ils
connaissent pas tout ce que fait la
région
ils savent pas tous seuls transports les
lycées y pense que c'est ce qu'ils
seront plus après par contre ils
connaissent les régions dans le domaine
culturel et dans le domaine sportif
parce qu'on se tourne en proximité vers
nous je rappelle disons le parce que
aujourd'hui moi j'suis pas dans une
émission de campagne électorale que les
choses soient claires on est là pour
éclairer nos habitants ils sont sur ce
qu'ont fait les régions sort ce qu'elle
fonde bien et sur ce qu'elles pourront
demain envisagé en fonction des
engagements qu'elles ont rappelé aux
noms et yves opina aussi
et rappelons nous rappelons nous que la
bourgogne et la franche-comté sont des
régions très sportive très culturel
aussi mais très sportive et que nous
n'entrons pas dans ton pas de mal à
faire baisser le niveau d'activités
sportives
il nous reste quelques minutes avant la
fin de cette émission peut être quelques
questions au général madame marie que je
crois que vous lire
interpellé une nouvelle fois les
présidents je voudrais je voulais
revenir sur les campus
vous avez mentionné tout à l'heure le
maintien des campus jeu l'enjeu n'est
t'il pas l'attractivité de nos campus et
comment amener bain des jeunes mais
aussi des enseignants chercheurs leur
famille sur ces sources à venir nous
rejoindre sur ses campus pour pour
étudier ou pour développer des
recherches fondamentales académique où
les recherches sont les soutiens réponse
or et soutient les post doc on
soutiendra l'idée c'est quand même
aujourd'hui que c'est ne faut pas qu'on
pense seulement universités dijon et
besançon belfort montbéliard ses 6000
étudiants un simili cuir à côté donc il
ya aussi pensons à l'ensam de cluny
pensons au creusot pensera aux as donc
il faut bien que d'abord la cie un point
sur lequel on peut inviter aujourd'hui
c'est la volonté que nous avons de
maintenir ces doses et de les développer
dans leur spécialité et dans leur
complémentarité parce qu'il a des
complémentarités à faire entre elles je
pense par rapport à votre question que
la fusion
alors cette fois ci non pas des régions
mais des universités la fusion des
universités va nous permettre la
construction d'une carte des formations
communes va permettre un dialogue fort
entre les universités et l'état pour
obtenir des moyens forts et le but c'est
de faire en sorte qu'il y ait un
enrichissement de cette carte des
formations pour que justement des jeunes
des parents soient motivés par cette
région et par cette université de
franche comté si des concurrents sont
dorel à lyon qui est bonne attractivité
de l'université de bourgogne franche
comté face à lyon passe à paris face à
strasbourg
elle passe par la fusion pour justement
une carte des formations beaucoup
plus attractive jean michel mathé je
crois vous aviez aussi une question ou
là je quitte ma casquette culturel
question plus de citoyens qu'elle pourra
être au niveau du tourisme une politique
commune à une grande région avec une
petite fille grandit la cité c'est déjà
assez compliqué avec toutes les
différentes strates qui ont chacune leur
leur leur communication leur stratégie
est ce que vous imaginez que vous avez
planché sur la question
je me pose la question quand même de la
petite kia tourisme qui nous fait pas
peur c'est vraiment celui là parce qu'on
on pense là qu'on est dans la dans la
complémentarité et que l'union des
forces bourguignonne qui sont énormes
l'union des forces comtoise qui sont
déterminés en matière de tourisme
ça va vraiment donner du plus ça alors
on a déjà nos instances un comité
régional de tourisme qui travaillent
ensemble pour que très bientôt il n'y
ait plus qu'un crt un comité régional du
tourisme pour qu'on aille vendre à
l'extérieur avec encore plus de force
cette région vinicole cette région avec
des paysages aussi varié avec un
patrimoine naturel et bâti d'une
richesse exceptionnelle
non franchement la bourgogne france
comté c'est un plus formidable en
matière de tourisme pas d'inquiétude
donc françois patriat pas d'inquiétude
images voudrait dire que nous sommes là
aujourd'hui non pas pour faire campagne
mais pour dire la grandeur des régions
et b donner un exemple pour faire
sourire à la fin heureusement qu' à la
loi on ne faire avancer que si on avait
interrogé les gens souffrir dans quatre
ans encore a compté bien on n'aurait pas
fusionner pour le double exemple la loi
dit les régions fusionnent dans deux ans
ça sera fait la loi avait dit essayer de
réunir de fusionner les universités
ça fait huit ans qu'on a commencé pour
encore cinq ans pour y arriver 13 ans 13
ans si on y arrive au bout et que la loi
elles permettent parfois d'accélérer les
choses de les faire bouger est ce que
j'espère moi c'est dans le bon sens mais
c'est gênant
nous sommes demandeurs nos d'une réunion
de travail technique entre les
associations d'usagers le bourgogne et
de franche-comté et vos services
nous ne voulons pas laisser vos services
aux seules mains des opérateurs
ferroviaires officiel il a qu'un pour le
moment en france sur le ter des montants
ne pas le citer
mais je préférerais que ce soit comme ça
une réunion de travail
mais je pense que c'est une excellente
proposition - il faut absolument qu
effectivement les représentants des deux
fédérations d'usagers se rencontrent
effectivement avec nos deux régions
est ce que justement la fédération des
usagers vont fusionner puisqu'on parle
souvent
après tout vous ne prenez pas pour la
prochaine réunion a lieu le 2 juillet at
all nous avons choisi la capitale de la
province ancien pour compte propre
compte et pour me réunir le 2 juillet
peut-être pour conclure est ce qu'il ya
un dispositif prévu pour accompagner la
population à tous les changements et
toutes les populations qui sont
directement concernés par par les
compétences du conseil régional est-ce
que c'est prévu à les consommatrices
positif à voltalia ya des événements
ponctuels mais il ya surtout une
mobilisation citoyenne a créé parce que
vous savez ils n'ont pas tendu
aujourd'hui les représentants du ccrt de
la culture du sport pour se concerter de
l'économie aujourd'hui je vois par
exemple je prends un exemple la cgpme
aujourd'hui travaille sur commande
m'avait alors une cgpme pour une franche
comté j'imagine que le medef va faire la
même chose dont les acteurs chacun dans
leur territoire travaillent aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas besoin de plus
pas encore financer ce genre d'activité
n'ont pas ce genre de rapprochement et
la prochaine étape c'est donc le vote de
chaque assemblée sur le chef-lieu
provisoire c'est fin du mois on verra si
vous êtes d'accord
alors c'est provisoire on va on peut
aimer porter pour cette question il a
été dit tellement de choses
moi je on peut être dans un débat
stérile
les bourguignons veulent que le chef
lieu soit à dijon les promoteurs veulent
que le chef lieu soit à besançon moi je
dis équilibre des forces entre les deux
et ça ira bien
c'est ce que dit aussi le gouvernement
allait on verra ça donc à la fin du mois
c'est la fin de cette émission merci en
tout cas à tous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
sachez que vous pouvez voir ou revoir
cette émission sur notre site internet
faire et tout de suite et bien c'est la
suite du 12/13 merci à tous nos invités
d'avoir participé aux deux présidents et
puis bien prochain rendez vous avec ma
voix ellipses et samedi prochain en
bourgogne et en franche comté
envie de sortir wazi la météo près de
chez vous avec le casino de bourbon
l'archambault